zuvor in anderen bereich arbeiten aber
hier bei cannabis fast dieselbe arbeit
also nichts gewusst unterschied eine
geruch musste trainer wenn also der
henker fest alle kleidung hahn überall
da war aber es geht man gewöhnt sich
dran
drogen oder hoffnungsschimmer 4
millionen patienten
ich bin jetzt seit ungefähr zweieinhalb
jahren cannabis patient erstattet von
der krankenkasse ich habe erstmal
vorerst im ausprobiert über ein
schwarzmarkt eben und später einfach
weil das cannabis vom schwarzmarkt im
teuer ist und einfach auch keine
sicherheit hat habe ich dann eben selbst
angebaut seite mache dieses jahres
produziert die kanadische kernebeck rot
das weltweit größte unternehmen seiner
art ihr medizinisches cannabis für den
europäischen markt in kanada ist derzeit
rund ein prozent der bevölkerung für
medizinisches cannabis registriert wir
denken dass diese quote auch in
deutschland in den nächsten jahren
erreicht werden kann
[Musik]